I've been working quite a few years on
the sage project and the sage project
has had yeah boohoo
sage math glad go them we've had
interactive widgets for about the last
five years or so it and so I've been
working on those for about the last
year's and then was really excited when
Fernando and the ipython folks I drew a
widget system as well so I've been
helping them design the ipython widget
system now just so I understand my
audience better how many people here is
look okay great and how many people have
used at some point okay quite a bit last
but maybe excited about it today so the
idea behind widgets is we're gonna solve
this problem of the feedback loop and
computation so typically a computation
we design a railroad phenomena of some
kind and then we put them up this model
and then we run the model and have some
results and it realize our results
aren't exactly what the real world was
so we change our model and then we
program it up and then we visualize with
results somehow or or look at the
results somehow and this feedback loop
is is really quite owners sometimes and
and it takes a long time and so by the
time you in time you want to run it I
say you have the competition and say you
want to run a variant of the Carbide you
up to the car we evaluate the code see
yeah where's that this where's the
speakers yeah oh that's okay maybe I
stand over here to the betting all right
so what the widgets are trying to do is
make this feedback loop between
adjusting a computation and visualizing
your results much faster than editing
code and rerunning code etc instead we
can drag a slider and get this loop
almost instantaneous or at least as fast
as the computation can run and so we can
play with parameter values quite a bit
and then adjust our model if we need to
the other reason we like widgets is
because sometimes people don't like the
program right we're doing a system and
we're trying to show it to our boss or
you know the salesperson or whoever you
know no offense the salespeople but it's
really nice for an end user to be able
to adjust a computation adjust
parameters and computations by just
dragging a slider versus going up to
code and figuring out where the number
is and editing the code and rerunning a
computation so the big idea behind
widgets is we've got paired Python and
JavaScript objects that sync a set of
data so you have a Python object and a
JavaScript object and they share some
attributes that are automatically synced
back and forth what this means is your
back end and your front end share a set
of data that can change it can change on
the front end and automatically
reflected to the back end and you can
change on the back end and automatically
reflect it on the front end on the
JavaScript side we have this data and
then we can render views of it in in
different ways so we can have multiple
views of a JavaScript model and in
different cells or different ways of
representing it and and so we have a
single model multiple views on the
JavaScript side and the views typically
are the things that we see and they live
in a special area above the ipython
outputs ok so here's an app I'm gonna
make this a little bit smaller so this
code fits a little bit better all right
if I may can you can you read this
okay so what we're doing here is a
slider widget this is just a slider if I
run this cell you'll see it's a initial
value is 20 by default the min and Max
are 0 to 100 and description is this
little label right here and you notice
printed something even before I
displayed slider but because widgets
right now an IDE Python always show up
at this area above the output have the
output appearing below the widget and so
you can see I can move this slider
around and I can change it on the front
end on the pipe ipython notebook side
the JavaScript side and then in the
Python side that was automatically
reflected back to Python and the value
of x saying X is the float slider widget
the value of x is 65.5 what we've done
and it goes the other way too we can
change the value here and it change in
the slider so this means you have
programmatic control over your over your
GUI that you're building in the front
end and you have automatic input from
that GUI in the back end so we have more
complicated objects widgets widgets
contain references to other widgets and
widgets can trigger events so here's an
example I'll even put this on the next
line so we're gonna create a witch at a
text widget says hi mom I'm on a budget
but button widget that has a label of
leave and we're define a reset function
and then we're going to do something
with that reset function so first of all
we evaluate this out we get hi mom and
then the button and notice this
container widget here it has a reference
to two other widgets so we can nest
widgets out of each other and this turns
out to be extremely powerful when we're
talking about really complicated systems
of widgets later this reset function
note you notice that I can set any value
of these GUI controls on the Python site
or automatically be reflected on the
JavaScript side question
yes yeah good question so the question
is this sometimes we get into trouble
when we try to reflect changes from
JavaScript to Python and sometimes we do
it too often so for example with the
text box every time I type a new
character it sends that value back to
Python which is bad if you want the
whole string as a single object we're
fixing that for ipython 3.0 I think and
you have to make a change on the
JavaScript side in order to in order to
say don't send changes as often and if I
remember right the text widget for
ipython 3.0 has this option if not we
can back port it well ipython 3.0 is
supposed to come out any day now or
maybe any week now or any month now but
so but we can back for it that could
talk afterwards about that all right so
what do we do we set the value of the
textbox - goodbye mom and then we change
the children of the form so we're going
to delete one of the controls now
alternative that we could do is we could
just make the button invisible what what
is the effect of this we say hi mom we
press leave and the button disappears
because the form reference is the be is
now disappeared from the children and
the text value has changed so you can
see you have lots of control over this
GUI one cool thing so this is something
we've done in sage for about five years
now and Brian Granger worked it with the
ipython widgets automatically guessing a
GUI so you have some arbitrary function
so here's a function I think this is
from Brian actually it just computes two
waveforms added together let's see right
here we add the two waveforms together
and what happens is you get some beading
so this is for example tune with the
tuning fork and so we just have this
just random function that we've done and
we want to automatically visualize it
and so we do this interact in
active we give it the function name and
then tell it the print for the for each
parameter whether the values and
automatically guesses a GUI control or
you can specify a GUI control if you'd
like automatically just as a GUI control
it says ah f1 and f2 they look like
their ranges of floats so let's put a
slider in there and now as we adjust the
slider you notice that it regenerates
this it reruns the function every time
the input parameters change and so you
know when you're tuning piano you hear
this there's the beating of those
frequencies you get even closer and so
you can play with this I come from I
work at Bloomberg now but I moved to
Bloomberg and in June and before that I
was working as a program as a math
professor at Drake University and these
are amazing and teaching to be able to
give students easy controls easy to
design controls right if professor all
he has to do is write this stuff and
then just call it interactive and boom
the student can play with it it's also
great on the job when you have somebody
you want to show a result but you don't
want to show all this code etcetera and
there's a there's a way that someone can
play with um we can also trigger event
so you notice that we have this sinking
back and forth changes but but three
times piece of data changes and a model
we can trigger an event so on the Python
side we use trait 'lets which is modeled
after the end thought traits from a
quite a while ago and on the JavaScript
side we use backbone which is a standard
JavaScript framework for zone events and
things like this and so what are we
doing here we create a slider widget so
this time it's an int slider widget from
0 to 100 default value of 30 and then we
want someone to be able to see the
square of this and so we could instruct
the latex widget and the latex widget is
a using mathjax to typeset your latex
and the value is going to be this
square of the VEX anytime things change
for the slider I want it to reset the
value of the textbox and so how do I do
that I defined something that will have
the effect that I want you're resetting
the value of the textbox and then I say
this is using that the trait 'lets which
is moderate modeled after the in thought
traits extra on trait change I'm going
to execute this function when X's value
parameter changes and then I display it
and what you see is anytime I change the
slider it treat it I change the slider
on JavaScript side sinks that value back
to the Python side the Python value
changes and the Python value change then
triggers an event which appears this
callback right and it resets the textbox
and so you end up being able to do
complex interactions between things and
complex effects
triggers of any of the data changing we
can do more fun things with that we can
link together widget so this this
triggering is really nice and sometimes
you want values to be exactly mirrored
between we just want to keep two widgets
in sync and so we we abstracted out this
mechanism to a simple functional link
function and trail it's okay so what are
we doing here I import the link function
for my Python I create two sliders first
slider is a value the second slider is
supposed to control the max of the first
slider so I'm setting this slider right
here is controlling the backs of this
slider right and how do I actually hook
that up make the interaction work I'm
using this link I say link the Max
attribute of the X which is a slider the
value attribute of the X max which is
this slider okay it's each other or you
can hook four or five attributes all in
a row you know all these five attributes
should be kept in sync so what's a okay
so we have X it's changing and if we
change the max of X you can guess what
happens
all of a sudden that max goes down so
say we change to max down to 72 and now
you see the max is 72 if you change the
max less and Max is now 61 so we can
have pretty easily sort of really
complex interactions here just by
linking up you know I want whatever the
slider is I want its value to show up
down here so I linked the textbox value
and the slider value we can actually
just happening on the Python side
sometimes the lag of sending a value
back changing another value and then
sending this value back to JavaScript
for the other slider sometimes that lag
is it's kind of onerous so we can
actually push this link to the
JavaScript side you have to write some
JavaScript code and we've got a pull
request in this and we're debating what
if it arms in that Python or in a
separate library but we could hook
things up on the JavaScript side using
the backbone events and in that case you
know these two are kept sink and sink in
the JavaScript and then both of their
changes are mirrored back to Python one
of the things so this this this emphasis
is where data should live and where
events and things like that should live
notice no matter many times I display
these two sliders different views of the
same model I still want them all linked
up and so this event that I want to have
happen really is an event linking two
models together so remember we had two
different objects on the JavaScript side
a model and a view so a model has
possibly lots of views and this is a
sort of thing we want to put in the
model cuz we're looking up to the
attributes we're hooking up to models
other times we want to put events and
effects and things like that in the view
and and one thing that I've learned in
working with these things is just a
simple thought process is whatever I'm
doing does it make sense for it to
happen every place this thing is
displayed if it does then make that
effect happen in the model or put that
data in the model or do I want this
effect or whatever I'm trying to do to
happen in one view but
not affect other views in that case put
the effect in the view so this comes
when you're reading the Java code for it
for its if you want to do custom widgets
all right some more advanced stuff
distributing widgets this is a problem
that we have not solved yet
but lots of people are experimenting for
example somebody Otto pian released not
a widget but but but it's something
similar to a widget and came up with
this formula and there's been other
people that have released widgets with
this sort of formula and it seems to
work out well remember you have Python
and JavaScript code that you need to
somehow communicate JavaScript code to
the front-end Python code to the backend
so one way to do this is if Jeff both
sets of code in a Python package just a
standard set of tools package and then
make inside of your package and install
the extension what that does is it calls
an i python function that copies the
javascript or links to javascript into a
standard place for for Java for a
user-defined JavaScript and ipython and
so you distribute a python package you
have a function that user has to run in
order to copy the javascript code over
to ipython but it's just one function
they don't need to know anything else
you just run that function and then but
there's one other thing you have to I'll
tell the ipython notebook to load that
JavaScript code it's now now it can find
the JavaScript code but it doesn't know
how to load it yet and so you have to
add some stuff to the IP profiles
customer to load that javascript code
this is changing for high 3.0 and
ipython 3.0 will be able to
automatically load any widget javascript
code based on some metadata and the
widget so third step will disappear and
ipython 3.0
one other thing that you'll notice when
you're when you're designing widgets and
things like that is this sinking that
happens back and forth between
JavaScript and Python is done in JSON so
how many people are familiar with JSON
the data interchange format yeah so so
it's wonderful and great but it's not
very rich right oh we've got his list
strings floats
you know dictionaries things like this
but it doesn't have like numpy arrays
and pandas data frames and you know
images and whatever else and so one of
the things you can if you design your
own widget if you design your own widget
is you can do custom serialization so
you can say my widget has like an umpire
ray well I can't send an umpire right
directly over JSON to the JavaScript
front-end so what I can do is when I
design the widget I can say this is how
to convert this particular value this
particular attribute to JSON and you do
this using the from in to JSON if you
want details on this come talk to me
afterwards change - 3.0 so the fun we've
talked about basically it you don't need
to pre load JavaScript code you can it
can load JavaScript code on the fly one
of the other things that you'll notice
if you start designing widgets is that
when you have widgets that have
references to other widgets it gets
pretty complicated like keeping track
and keeping lists and sync with each
other and we're going to make that a lot
easier using something called a view
list in ipython 3.0 we're working on
persistence right now if you save the
notebook and open it back up again the
widgets are gone and be viewer widgets
are gone and we're working on being able
to save widgets so that if you open it
back up again the widgets are still
there you don't have to be executed
notebook and we're changing a bunch of
name since it's actually already
happened entry container widget for
example it goes to box so it's a little
awkward okay one last thing one of the
things I worked on quite a bit on the
grant first page with students at Drake
University where I was teaching was to
write a 3d graphic rendering for ipython
notebook so the idea here is we've got a
pretty standard pretty comprehensive
WebGL 3d graphics library on the
JavaScript side called 3GS and we want
to wrap this library
using widgets so that we can manipulate
any part of a scene from Python so the
basic idea here is really basic idea is
we have a bunch of objects on the
JavaScript side we figure out which
attributes we want to expose and we wrap
them in a Python widget so each Python
widget corresponds to JavaScript jsr
through JSF and then when we render what
we do is we when we display a Python
widget was there a JavaScript side and
it creates the corresponding object and
adds it to a scene graph so what happens
is is you don't actually see in the HTML
page all of these things that are being
rendered there scene graph nodes and a
3d scene graph but they're being
collected into a single 3d scene and
then rendered here's an example let's
see
so in this example I create basically a
surface by by creating the Z values I
create a surface geometries it's one of
these objects here's the Z values and
some other parameters I create a mesh by
taking a geometry object and a and a and
some sort of material that can be pretty
complicated here it's pretty simple I
now I'm creating a scene by taking that
surface and a light and I'm adding to
that surface also the wireframe lines
it's also sort of mesh grid of some kind
I'm wrapping it all up into a scene then
I'm adding a camera to the scene that
can just any parameters of the camera
and then I render the scene and and add
some interaction controls here and the
result is 3d graphics and the ipython
notebook and this is 3d graphics that I
could control any part of this from
Python and I can change the light around
I can add a picker that tracks the
motion of my mouse cursor and then
reflect the current coordinate back to
Python I can even have a camera widget
that takes a picture of your face and
then creates a texture and puts your
faith on this 3d object the
possibilities are endless here all right
the pie Fuji hood is up on pub right now
it's in a state of flux because I'm
trying to prepare it for AI 533 point oh
so it may or may not work but but it's
all up if you want to see a really
complicated example of a system of
widgets that are all interconnected and
linked together all right thank you
we have time for questions
whoever's in charge all hostess knows
this notebook up sure yeah the ipython
notebook runs in the browser so it's
transitive here so so the is do run in
the browser but they need the ipython
infrastructure in order to run so are
you asking can I get these to run on
just like a normal webpage instead of
the ipython notebook so there's a couple
ways you can distribute a file of the
JavaScript copy it into a special
location and just call it from your from
your ipython notebook server or you can
do what I did down here when I was
preparing but this so there's a bunch of
initialization codes here and you notice
this right here you can make a cell with
the % % javis put all your JavaScript
code in there if you really want to so
you can just distribute a single ipython
notebook that has a bunch of code in
cells JavaScript and Python you can do
here is basically send this snippet of
JavaScript to the front end and it'll be
executed there not as easily though
Jonathan Fredrik worked on something
that lets you do that using widgets so
there's some pretty interesting
capabilities there
I'm sorry start from the widget end with
the widget or the certain or the
specific values that are in the widget
yeah so because all the changes are
reflected immediately and because you
can hook into events into those changes
what you could do is write a function
that stores every time this widget
changes store its value in a database
and and so that way you can create your
own provenance system where you're
storing your tracking every single
change of these widgets and then you can
replay them and everything I think that
would be a cool feature to see actually
in my Python or at least the idea of
being able to set bookmarks or some kind
of yeah that's right that's right
there's okay so yes yeah right now can
we do it there's built-in ipython stuff
we can't save changes right now with
built-in ipython but you can build your
own and and contribute it upstream I'd
love to see it
any other questions all right thank you
very much if you want more information
feel free to go on the ipython user list
and ask questions feel free to contact
me directly or Jonathan Fredrik who's
the main author of the ipython widgets
or Brian Granger who's the main author
of the notebook we're happy to help we'd
love to see a lot of exciting advances
in this area thank you